we're going to take a break from the
coronavirus we have an update on a legal
battle in California on death row there
a death row inmate that has captured
worldwide attention including from Pope
Francis and Kim kardashian-west
Kevin Cooper is his name he's always
maintained that he did not kill three
members of a family and a guest staying
at their house back in 1983 last year
California Governor that's Gavin Newsom
ordered more DNA testing and new
witnesses came forward who now tie the
crime to someone else Erin Moriarty has
been reporting on this case for two
decades she meets with Cooper
face-to-face in this week's 48 hours my
first visit to San Quentin prison to
finally meet Kevin Cooper came shortly
after he learned he'd get new DNA tests
we were not allowed to record the visit
but Cooper talked about his hopes that
the tests would prove what he has said
all along that he was framed for the
murders finding somebody to pin it on
was very important and Kevin Cooper was
a convenient person to pin it on Kevin
Cooper's attorney Norman Heil the
problem was they didn't have the
evidence Cooper's case has come into the
spotlight in part because Kim
kardashian-west who also visited him has
taken up his cause as well as New York
Times columnist Nicholas Kristof there
is enormous amount of evidence that
suggests three or four white
perpetrators I believe that there was
evidence planted Cooper and his defense
team hoped that new DNA tests of the
evidence might reveal other suspects but
they also worried that too much time has
passed this evidence was collected years
and years and years ago at the time
evidence wasn't handled very well
it wasn't stored well and in fact
defense attorney Becca Barlow a DNA
specialist says her worst fears were
realized most of the DNA and the
evidence was too degraded for testing
except for an orange towel believed to
have been taken from the Ryan family
home we have a single male profile that
is not Kevin Cooper's and there's been
another discovery a vial that contain
Cooper's blood all these years turned up
empty to have an entire vial disappear
like that raises all sorts of
questions in my mind Cooper's defense
statements also gather more information
collecting affidavits from five
witnesses why someone else to the case
now Kevin Cooper has a new plea for the
California governor a full innocence
investigation he is somebody who
believes in the truth and is willing to
fight for it
Erin Moriarty joins us now from a studio
in New York good morning to you Erin I
remember you coming to the table at our
broadcast Center telling us about this
story this sounds promising well it does
but it's been such a long process you
know this case this this actual murder
happened in 1983 when I went to see him
in San Quentin
I'd always talked to him over the phone
but I had never seen him face to face
it was so sobering because when there's
a person on death row you talk to him in
a Plexiglas box literally you're not
allowed to record it but I found him
incredibly intelligent well-read and
amazingly very optimistic that some day
he's going to clear his name
even Pope Francis has become interested
in this case Aaron as well as Kim
kardashian-west as we mentioned why is
that I can make a very simple because
you have one man on death row and the
early evidence all indicated that there
were multiple assailants the only
eyewitness who lived through this said
there were three men white men I should
point out also the car that was stolen
had three seats with blood on it three
weapons were used anyone who looks at
this case whether your celebrity or not
you will think something is off
very interesting so you've been
reporting on this for two decades Aaron
I'm curious does anything surprised you
with these latest developments oh
absolutely and I mentioned it in that
piece and we'll talk about it more
tomorrow night but so they took blood
they may have taken two vials of blood
from Kevin Cooper supposedly that should
have been there there was preservative
this year and when they pulled this out
the vial it's empty and of course the
defense has always said that blood was
plan
the evidence so it looks so suspicious
that surprised me no blood at all in
that vial just president questions there
Aaron all right Aaron thank you you can
see Aaron's report the troubling case
against Kevin Cooper tomorrow night at
10:00 9:00 central right here on CBS